bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission où on se permet même de vous
parler de choses qui ont disparu
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler du plan de relance du plan de
relance de la commission européenne
bonjour est ce thème bonjour olivier
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ces caches
une émission consacrée cette semaine
vous l'avez dit olivier au plan de
relance de la commission européenne que
contient-il à quoi va-t-il servir
concrètement pourquoi ce plan ne fait il
pas l'unanimité auprès des pays membres
se sont allés questions que nous allons
nous poser dans cette émission et pour
cela nous serons en deuxième partie avec
costas boto poulos ex président de
l'autorité grecque des marchés
financiers pour tenter de contrer la
récession liée à la crise du colis de 19
la présidente de la commission
européenne
ursula von der leyen a présenté le 27
mai dernier un plan de relance 750
milliards d'euros doivent être mis sur
la table tous les détails de ce plan b
avec le tiroir cash d'antoine d'assas ça
y est après plusieurs mois d'absence les
tiroirs cachée de retour cette semaine
nous parle du plomb à 750 milliards
présenté fin mai par la présidente de la
commission européenne ursula von der
leyen
baptisé avec un nom bien cool next
generation eeyou c'est le plus ambitieux
des plans de relance j'avais proposé en
europe
750 milliards qui viennent s'ajouter à
la somme rondouillard de 2 540 milliards
déjà mises en place dans l'urgence on va
pas rentrer dans les détails du montage
financier complexe mais en gros l'argent
serait d'emprunter sur les marchés avec
la garantie de l'état et ne devrait être
remboursé qu'à partir de 2028
en gros de la dette quoi les pays les
plus touchés par la pandémie récupère
est forcément plus comme l'italie avec
plus de 170 milliards ou l'espagne avec
plus de 140 milliards et la france bat
39 milliards un dixième de la somme
irait aux entreprises privées et enfin
une partie du gâteau irait aux systèmes
de santé des pays membres qui ont montré
dirons-nous quelques lacunes ces
derniers mois bref un beau plan de
relance qui montre une belle solidarité
européenne pour tous tous nos cars en
europe quatre pays autriche pays bas
danemark et suède résiste encore et
toujours au plan de relance
après les cours au gabon après le plan
franco allemand
pas sûr qu'ils acceptent celui là lors
du vote mi juin
et si ça bloque quelques mois après le
break site
ce serait encore un coup dur pour lui
olivier a pour commencer votre avis sur
ce plan de relance proposé par la
commission européenne
c'est le énième d'abord avec toujours un
un nom d'une partie des dpi et on voit
un qu' il est notoirement insuffisant
regardez ce qui se passe par exemple aux
états unis donc on voit qu'il est
notoirement insuffisant on voit que
comme d'habitude on rajoute de la bête
parce que on aime ça on aime beaucoup la
bête
les banquiers centraux aime beaucoup la
bête les gouvernements aiment énormément
la dette et donc on fait de la peine
parce qu'on sait pas faire autre chose
et puis la troisième chose c'est que
c'est toujours à chaque fois soumis à
des conditions soumis à des conditions
de 2 de management on va dire un peu
comme le m us si vous voulez c'est à
dire qu'on re décline à chaque fois le
ms c'est à dire qu'on dit ok on prête on
prête aux pays qui en ont besoin donc
italie l'espagne
s on prête aux pays qui en ont besoin
mais c'est sous condition d'avoir
certaines réformes et c'est donc
toujours la même chose
vous avez avant c'était la troïka vous
avez en fait une espèce de troïka qui
prend la main et qui va décider à la
place des gouvernements de ce qu'il faut
faire ou de ce qu'il faut pas faire dans
les pays donc en fait il n'y a pas
finalement que les les pays du nord et
de l'est qu'ils sont qui sont contre ce
genre de choses il ya aussi les pays qui
en bénéficieraient mais qui n'ont pas
envie que gouvernants leur place paraît
c'est logique
olivier vous évoquiez la rapidement
avant de passer à la deuxième partie
vous évoquez les états unis en quoi
est-ce qu'on part avec le plan de
relance proposé par le vous savez que le
pib européen est un petit peu supérieur
au pib américain est regardée 750
milliards ce que ça fait par rapport au
pib européen donc on est loin du compte
on est très très loin du compte et puis
je vous dis alors après vous pouvez
appeler sa subvention vous pouvez
appeler ça après soit c'est un un don et
à ce moment là les 500 milliards vous
les reverrai pas soit vous êtes c'est un
prêt vous pouvez l'appeler subventions
s'ils voulaient mais vous êtes vous êtes
tout de même dans quelque chose qui va
falloir à un moment financer alors je
sais pas si vous avez vu récemment
monsieur thierry breton qui nous a
annoncé vouloir faire un impôt européen
il va falloir finalement financer tous
et tous ses prêts et tous et toutes ces
gabegies et donc que nous annonce un
impôt européen qui sera évidemment
rassurez vous refusez mais en revanche
l'impôt qu'on installera en france d'ici
la fin de l'année lui sera pas refuser
merci olivier on passe tout de suite à
la deuxième partie de cette émission
et pour évoquer le plan de relance de la
commission européenne nous sommes en
liaison avec costaz boto poule au sexe
au président de l'autorité grecque et
des marchés financiers
bonjour monsieur moto poulos merci à
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation bienvenue dans ces caches et
alors on est venus à via le
tiroir-caisse notamment lé détaillants
du plan de relance de la commission
européenne vous quel est votre regard
sur ce projet ça vous je suis reprendra
pas assez d'ailleurs je crois la raison
pour laquelle vous m'avez arrêté que je
suis pas d'accord avec la présentation
qui a été faite notamment pas monsieur
de la marche que je salue repassant et
je le sais je lui souhaite du bien
doc c'est pas du tout les mêmes plans à
mes yeux c'est un plan tout à fait
nouveau je veux pas utiliser des mots un
peu grandiloquent à dire que c'est un
plan historique
j'aime parler comme ça les mots qui ne
disent rien mais c'est vrai que c'est un
plot très original est ce un plan qui
fait à mes yeux un bond qualitatif pour
l'europe qu'on n'a jamais vus
pourquoi un bond qualitatif c'est
justement les caractéristiques comme
monsieur de la match n'a pas évoqué et
cours vous êtes cette dernière que j'ai
je j'évoque moi même tout d'abord pour
la première fois on parle d'une bête
commune donc un tabou est brisé
il y a une dette commune puisque
l'argent sera soulevée si je puis dire
sur les marchés avec la garantie de
l'union européenne sous la gare au petit
du budget européen
donc c'est pas les pays chacun pour soi
comme à des motions de la marque
mais si m c'est bien l'union européenne
qui va mettre son sens sur ce programme
deuxième mort 2eme d'amour brisée
il y aura bien été transferts
budgétaires puisque comme vous l'avez
évoqué l'argent ira plus vers les pays
aux plus grandes difficultés
donc le sud de le jeu
l'union européenne pas seulement la
grèce d'ailleurs mais plutôt et
principalement l'italie et l'espagne
donc c'est des vrais transferts
budgétaires qui s'opère pour la première
fois et pour briser deuxième tableau 3e
d'amour qui sera brisée si tout cela se
concrétise bien sûr parce que on parle
on ne parle que d'une proposition de la
commission rend à l'état actuel des
choses mais on doit parler de ce qu'on a
sur la table donc troisième tabou qui
sera brisé sa thabo politique puisque on
a des priorités pour les petites
communes
c'est le fameux green new deal au bois
français et l'économie informatique ou
les villes la transition digitales aux
meilleurs français
donc ça aussi c'est nouveau on monte
tout cet argent pour faire des réformes
commune pour tout et pas seulement la
zone euro d'ailleurs mais pour toute
l'union européenne et 4e témoins avaient
à un moment parce que un mot parce qu'il
ya la chose la plus importante
4e 4e singularité importante
il y a des ressources propres pour la
première fois dans le budget européen on
parle en laissant un peu de côté le
poids du budget mais on parle pour la
première fois des ressources importantes
propres pour l'union europenne
ressources propres
ça veut dire politique économique
commune et tout ça c'est des nouveautés
très importante à mes yeux
alors avant de revenir assure tout s'est
à nouveau terminé je voudrais vous faire
réagir sur ce principe de deyne de dette
commune le a été a beaucoup critiqué au
début de l'épidémie notamment pour ses
difficultés à parler d'une seule voix
est-ce que là notamment avec le principe
de mutualisation des dettes sans message
d'unité que je souhaite aussi passé et
le lèche chier ils peuvent passer tous
les messages qui veulent vous avez comme
le feu comme vient de le dire notre
invité c'est un projet et vous avez des
gens qui sont vent debout contre ce
projet ce qui est assez logique
vous vous allez financer comment cette
histoire
vous savez que la bête c'est de l'impôt
futur donc en effet monsieur thierry
breton vient nous expliquer qu'on va
payer des impôts est ce que vous pensez
que vous avez des gens qui dans aux pays
bas ou en france vont vouloir aller
payer des impôts pour pour les grecs
pour les italiens pour les espagnols ça
ne marche pas ça ne fonctionne pas c'est
encore une tentative désespérée d'avoir
un une europe fédérale et s'enfoncer
dans les robes fédérale alors qu'on sait
que l'europe est morte
enfin un acte et qu'elle est morte et
est le premier qui devrait en être
heureux c'est notre invité qui est grec
et je pense que la glace est assez
souffert de leurs deux on ne pas vouloir
continuer armée si on va marquer une
courte pause on revient dans un instant
bienvenue à danser cash si vous nous
rejoignez nous sommes avec costas boto
paulo c'est que ce président de
l'autorité grecque à des marchés
financers financiers pour évoquer ce
plan présenté par la commission
européenne monsieur bouton poule juste
avant la pub olivier delamarche évoqué
une europe morte
qu'est ce que vous avez à répondre à
cela que c'est tout le contraire
à mes yeux c'est une réponse à ceux qui
disent que l'europe est morte parce que
tout simplement c'est une page une
nouvelle on va voir moi je suis très
prudent on va voir les résultats
concrets mais puisqu'on parle
aujourd'hui puisqu'on débattent
aujourd'hui il faut parler du projet et
on est en train de parler d'un projet
mais faut-il aussi que je crois en tout
ont été comme monsieur de la maxe
exagère aussi sur la résistance qu'il y
aura sur sur ce plan les fameux 4
frugaux les quatre pays qui rechigne
dit on a payé de la dore leur réaction
officielle tout du moins a été prudente
mais positive ces quatre pays auquel
vous faites référence et l'autriche les
pays bas la suède et le danemark est ce
qu'ils ont réellement les moyens de s'y
opposer
oui ton pays à moyens de s'opposer
puisque on doit trouver un consensus à
la à la fin du jour mais ce que j'étais
en train de dire c'est que la façon dont
l'europe aux graisses et pour une fois
le mot est réelle il ya un progrès
tangible la façon donc dans l'europe
grèce c'est à travers des négociations
c'est un travers le mot n'est pas un
roman des compromis donc il y aura
forcément un compromis il y aura un
compromis génération y moins le cas ça
personne ne sait aujourd'hui si ceux-ci
ce projet sera votée ou pas vous savez
que c'est l'unanimité que si vous avez
deux ou trois pays qui refusent cet
accord le cet accord ne sera pas ne sera
pas mis en place donc voilà après je je
je ne je ne
fais pas de plans sur la comète
aujourd'hui on n'en sait rien on verra
bien mais de toute façon
rassurez vous si ce plan là ne sort pas
au niveau de l'europe
vous aurez monsieur m'a conquis vous
annoncera que ils s'endettent tout seul
de 50 100 200 milliards de plus c'est
pas grave de toute façon c'est au final
c'est nous qui payons donc et
malheureusement on paiera de plus en
plus sachez le vous le je vous l'avais
dit il ya il ya quelques mois je vous
avais annoncé qu' on créerait un impôt
de plus
croyez moi ça va se faire d'ici la fin
de l'année et et on paiera sle
l'incompétence totale de nos dirigeants
que ce soient nationaux ou européens
le contenu de ce plan tous les pays ne
recevront un pas la même somme si l'on
combine après et subventions à l'italie
et à l'espagne sont allés principaux
bénéficiaires plus de 172 milliards
d'euros pour l'italie et plus de 140
milliards pour l'espagne de son côté est
la france devrait récupérer près de 39
milliards c'est un message fort selon
vous envoyez à ces pays du sud giuseppe
a compté le premier ministre italien a
qualifié ce plan dans un tweet je cite
d'excellents est signalé ce que vous
êtes d'accord est ce que c'est un
changement radical dans la politique
menée envers ces pays n'ont pas ouvert
ce pays
c'est un changement radical dans la
logique de l'union européenne je vous ai
une des 4 4 et speak politique c'est
quoi il ya transfert de fonds à ceux qui
nécessitent plus d'argent à cause d'une
situation qui dépasse
pour une fois la compétence politique
non pas aller au monsieur de la marque
la pandémie
c'est pas du tout la compétence poli
politique la dernière fois que j'avais
le plaisir de parler avec vous on
faisait référence à l'expulsion regrets
là c'était aussi
entre autres choses d une situation
politique
ici on est dans une situation d'un
problème qui dépasse la politique et
devant lequel donc la réaction de
l'europe
finalement parce que c'est vrai qu'on
n'est pas arrivé là sans problème et
sans obstacle
mais finalement la réponse c'est une une
reproche qui est politique et solidaire
une réaction on va il a bon dos le virus
c'est ça qui est magique c'est que lille
va ni va apporter la réponse à tout la
crise sanitaire va être la responsable
de tout moi j'y crois pas du tout je
voulais dit depuis longtemps le virus
c'est un déclencheur c'est un un
catalyseur c'est un agrégateur mais ça
n'est en aucun cas la racine du mal à la
racine du mal elle est là depuis bien
longtemps les gars qui n'ont pas attendu
les italiens ils ont pas attendu pour
pour avoir des problèmes pour avoir de
la bête pour avoir pour ne plus avoir de
croissance le comme id
c'était bien avant et donc le tout ça
c'est aller mettre tout sur le dos du
virus et de la crise sanitaire
c'est grotesque on a toujours les mêmes
les mêmes réflexes on a toujours les
mêmes raisonnements c'est normal ils ont
fait les mêmes écoles
ils ont ils sont tous passé par l'ena
donc qu'ils sont tous diplômés de la
même façon avec les mêmes idées avec les
mêmes réflexes soul et je vous parle
d'incompétence c'est là on a atteint les
sommets de l'incompétence et ça se voit
malheureusement ça se voit de plus en
plus salée que le recours systématique à
la bête est ce qu'il ya d'autres
solutions que la dette s'est passé par
recours à la dette
c'est un recours à défaut commun une
partie de l'argent qu'on met dans ses
fonds communs provient de la dette mais
de la dette dans le change que chez les
marchés
qui vont là qui vont la donne et il n'y
a pas plus démocratique et il n'y a pas
de façon plus petit et il n'a pas il n'y
a pas de façon plus solidaire de
financer des projets à l échelle et si
je peux me permettre aussi parce que
monsieur de la mâche invoqué mans pays
il faut dire parce que moi j'utilise pas
des qualificatifs pour mes propos il
faut dire que la grèce a bien mis de
l'ordre dans ses finances après coup
vous tapez et avec l'aide de l'union
européenne
mais c'est pas c'est pas la compétence
qui est toujours le problème le problème
c'est aussi de trouver la volonté
politique est mon propos il vaut ce
qu'il vaut
c'est à nos téléspectateurs de juger
c'est que pour une fois l'europe semble
trouver une volonté politique pour
marcher dans un avec un plan commun
c'est tout on va voir on va voir les
problèmes mais ce qui est certain à mes
yeux toujours c'est que l'europe n'est
pas du tout morte un mois maintenant sur
le financement de ce plan les
remboursements ne devrait pas commencer
avant 2028 et pourrait s'étaler jusqu'en
2058 est la commission a pourrait
envisager de nouvelles ressources
propres pour rembourser ses emprunts
plusieurs axes de travail sont sur la
table l'instauration d'une taxe carbone
aux frontières de l'union européenne
pourquoi pas une texte numérique qu'est
ce qui selon vous elle serait le plus
judicieux tout tôt il faut donc ça c'est
pas des taxes et de ressources propres
monsieur de la marque un bon économiste
faire un mélange parce que c'est parce
que je me lochert ses propos à mon avis
c'est pas c'est des ressources propres
de l'union européenne
bien sûr par des contributions
nationales
mais pour une fois des contributions
nationales qui sont liées à un projet
politique
tout ça est nouveau il faut souligner la
nouveauté objective de ce projet et
après il faut voir si ce projet se
concrétise csu ce projet trouve des
obstacles aux lignes et à une réaction à
sur ses ressources propres évoqué par
monsieur aboiteaux pour l'os et qui ne
sont pas des taxes
c'est énorme une taxe est pas une taxe
un emprunt c'est pas un emprunt c2c de
l'argent magique peut-être je ne sais
pas quand vous empruntez auprès des
marchés financiers c'est un emprunt ça
s'appelle un emprunt c'est pas un don
des marchés les marchés donne pas de
l'argent ça s'appelle un emprunt donc
faut mettre les bons mots sur les sur
les bonnes choses et une taxe je suis
déçu quand vous mettez un pourcentage
sur quoi que ce soit sur des revenus
ça s'appelle un impôt est une taxe alors
après vous pouvez vous pouvez lui donner
le nom vous voulez hein c'est pas ce pas
un problème moi je suis preneur si il ya
un langage progressiste qui appelle les
choses différemment mais ça n'empêche
que c'est une taxe c'est quand vous
faites un emprunt c'est quelque chose
qui se rembourse
voilà un exemple alors normal je sais
que maintenant on dit que les emprunts
s'est pas fait pour être remboursé à ce
moment là c'est pas un instinct donc
voilà si je vous donne quelque chose si
je vous donne mille balles et que je
vous dis tiens ces cadeaux et bien à ce
moment là vous n'aurez pas besoin en
effet de melay rembourser mais je veux
dire il faut quand même appeler les
choses par leur nom et dire les choses
le ça sert à rien d'essayer de coller
des de faire de la dialectique et coller
des des noms qui veulent rien dire sur
deux sur des choses des ressources
propres
il n'y a pas de ressources propres
puisque le europe
aujourd'hui encore moins avec son budget
qui est amputé de
du royaume uni excusez moi mais elle n'a
pas les moyens de sortir tout ça de sa
poche mais c'est pas il ya postes
européennes donc elle va aller emprunter
sur les marchés
donc c'est un emprunt et si elle vous
donc c'est bien des taxes voilà une
dernière action et messieurs voter pour
elle avant de s'inquiéter
oui une dernière réaction donc pour dire
les choses proprement
d'abord on parle de subventions on parle
pas dedans donc une partie la plus
grosse partie de cette énorme somme
c'est des subventions qu'est ce que ça
veut dire des subventions ça veut dire
que les pays mettent une partie de leur
produit national dans un budget commun
et c'est comme ça que ils remboursent
entre guillemets cette partie là est la
deuxième partie c'est comme vous dites
monsieur des emprunts et les emprunts ça
se rembourse et ça va se rembourser
d'autres entend donc en peau de l'argent
aujourd'hui pour rembourser dans 30 ans
ça ça s'appelle de la solidarité est la
troisième chose c'est que si ça existe
comme terminologie et comme notion les
ressources propres du budget européen et
c est ce qu on en est entre air aussi de
faire c'est pour ça que je qualifie tout
ça sont des paroles grandiloquente un
saut qualitatif très important merci
beaucoup monsieur qu au stade saputo
poule aux avoir été un parmi nous dans
cette émission je rappelle que vous êtes
l'ex président de l'autorité à grecs des
marchés financiers
comme chaque semaine olivier delamarche
répond à vos questions que vous lui
posez sur les réseaux sociaux et on
passe tout de suite à la première
question celle de borck lazare monsieur
de la marche
voyez-vous d'un bon oeil la
généralisation du télétravail et oui je
vais pas vous dire le contraire vu que
là j'y suis je suis chez moi et je
trouve ça très bien maintenant sur la
généralisation
il ya des métiers sur lequel c'est
facile et sur lequel on peut le faire il
ya des métiers sur lequel ça va être
beaucoup plus difficile
en plus ça ne ça ne favorise pas les
rapports humains et je ne suis pas sûr
que à terme
ce ne soit pas dangereux justement pour
en cette matière des rapports humains
à la question à d'hubert 66 que peut-on
faire pour freiner l'ascension à des
gaffes à à cause du confinement la taxe
à gaza est elle une bonne piste
on les taxe gaffe à d'abord sachez que
visiblement vous ne pourrez pas la
mettre en place pour la bonne et simple
raison que à chaque fois dans cette
belle robe qui n'a qu'un objectif c'est
le bien-être de tous les européens
évidemment chaque pays va plus ou moins
parce qu'il a des intérêts particuliers
va refuser une taxe gafa qui serait à
l'échelle européenne on l'a vu bruno le
maire l'avait proposé ça a été refusé
et ensuite il a dit qu'il le ferait tout
seul je veux dire il faut il faut bien
voir aujourd'hui justement ses gaffes à
sont toutes plus puissante que les
principaux pays et que donc le petit
bruno le maire tout ministre de
l'économie qu'il est va avoir bien du
mal à se faire respecter par des gens
qui sont dix fois plus puissant que lui
donc c'est quelque chose de global
peut-être qu'un jour un président
frasques avait fait ou svelte c'est à
dire une loi anti trust
si vous voulez et qu'il démantèlera
légal phare mais pour l'instant il faut
quand même composer avec et savoir que
leur imposerai rien du tout parce que si
vous essayez de leur imposer quelque
chose easywire merci à beaucoup olivier
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain rendez vous la
semaine prochaine
nos précédents numéros sont à voir ou à
revoir sur notre site internet arte
france point tv et n'oubliez pas de
poser toutes vos questions à olivier
delamarche sur les réseaux sociaux ou en
commentaire des vidéos
olivier va
dernier mot c'est un peu toujours la
même chose quand on parle d'europe
on vous explique que en dehors de
l'europe
ça sera long faire et que dans l'europe
on est vraiment tellement bien
eh bien je retourne la question je vous
dis à aux principaux intéressés que sont
les grecs les italiens les espagnols qui
n'ont pas l'air de trouver ça si bien
que ça